[Music]
when was the last time you guys
cried recently this morning this morning
recently what happened this morning well
let's not talk about it what were you
saying
recently with you with our with our
talks
like remember one time recently we had a
talk one time recently
remember a long time ago i think you're
remembering
as well as i am i don't remember this
how can i forget remember when
isaac was way younger but recently
though oh right right yes yes no yeah it
was a talk and then we were crying and
then it was just like really beautiful
and then like that was the most recent
time that i cried
joe what about you you don't come out
you don't come off to me as a
uh in march
or february no march no february maybe
yeah
why or quarantine happened huh yeah
that's right when it happened
no no no why me
you guys do you guys like i guess more
for the guys because i feel like
girls are more inclined to be okay with
crying i've had a huge period of my life
i cry every week um but not balling but
like
i cry movies all the time you guys watch
coco yeah
i love everything there's two parts of
that movie that make me [ __ ]
bald when miguel is singing to mama coco
oh i know
i'm just crying that part and then when
when at the in the cave
and then when the the reveal happens i'm
like i'm getting chills already
dude not even yeah i cried at my wedding
oh i did good job the wedding that you
invited me to that we ended up not going
to
so he invited you you didn't go well
uh it got i took your wedding i took
your invite away oh okay okay okay so he
and then he cries yeah that's why i
cried yeah that was around march
february i thought it was in july oh my
god
[Laughter]
all right so in japan there's a guy
named he defumi yoshida
and uh he's of course yes uh he's a
self-described
tear teacher and he teaches the thing
called uh
rui katsu which roughly translates
sounds delicious
[Laughter]
translates to tear seeking and he's a
tier
teacher so he is in the business of
encouraging people
to shed a few tears every once in a
while as a way to release stress
and to lead a happier life mm-hmm and uh
and the guys feel better after after
crying like yeah
yeah yeah it feels like you farted yeah
how about during crying uh i'm not even
aware
during crying it's like more like any
emotion that's
um uncontrollable it just it just goes
ham
what kind of what kind of feelings do
you feel when you're crying then if you
if you relate that to partying
it's comedy right i'm making i'm making
the comparison of a release like that's
not how i really feel
yeah but like no like if i had to be
serious about it
it is a different kind of release
something that was trapped
in your heart and your chest or whatever
and you've been
you didn't realize that this is
something that you needed to let go
true so it it the realization or or
whatever it is is is the is the freeing
part of it
i get that afterwards definitely exactly
yeah for sure
yeah i get that after the time but then
like during the crying process
i guess because i'm not allowing myself
to cry i don't know what it is but i get
this gigantic knot in my throat in my
chest sometimes i'm just like like i
can't even like fully like
let it all out don't they call that like
a frog in the throat is that what that
is referring to sure or am i just no
wait a frog isn't that we have like a
loki stuck and you're like talking
really weird and you have to go
like you can't breathe yeah yeah like
you know literally
yeah yeah that's exactly what it is my
bad that's what i was thinking of
actually have you seen this before not
for me
i just big david blaine fans for that
feeling that i get though that not in
the chest
feeling that i just like like i end up
feeling like i can't breathe
for that reason i don't like crying and
i don't like
watching movies that intentionally make
me cry what about after do you feel good
like
oh that was a good cry um if it's like
if i
if like there's like this threshold i
need to like surpass and once i surpass
that and i'm like
wailing and i'm just like like i can't
i can't hold it in and like i'm
literally like making like wailing
sounds
after those cries i feel amazing yeah
those are that's the catharsis though
that
you actually have to let it go out
otherwise it's just if it's leaking
and it's not actually like flooding out
you don't really get the same
uh kind of just that feeling of like
refreshing yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like peeing from the eyes
yeah
peeing farting from the other holding
your pee in from the eyes
when you're not allowed so when that so
i guess i never hold it in then when i
cry
it just it pees yeah and i just let it
go
and i'm like oh that was cool yeah i
struggle with letting that's good that's
good that's a healthy peer
yeah that is i get utis all the time in
my eyeballs
you won't get a uti if you do that
he cries like this
[Laughter]
because if it's out it's out man and
then when you're almost done you go
you're trying to shake it up
[Music]
all right so uh oh you know i just
remembered uh it was our our
the step dad video on her channel oh
it was after that i was after that oh it
was a private talk
okay anyways those videos make me cry
all the time
like even in that video i was crying
right but i was like holding it in
because i'm like [ __ ] keep it
together girl
see that's the feeling that like i i
always run into because um
you know when you're like watching a
movie and uh maybe it's because you
always know that you're capable of
crying and you never know when you're
gonna get triggered
it's not like oh this is a sad movie so
i'm gonna cry this time when it's like a
very sad movie and i don't cry
but there's times where it's like uh
just some
kind of sentimental moment that has some
sort of relative thing to like
i don't know daddy issues or some [ __ ]
that like randomly hits you then you
start
tearing up then you're like you have
this conversation with yourself you're
like
don't [ __ ] cry why the [ __ ] you
crying about this [ __ ] you know what i
mean it's like
you have that when i run into those i
don't get my catharsis
yeah that's true you know what i mean
because i'm like hella tired those are
tear jerkers
that's the majority of my cries yeah or
like when you start tearing up and then
you just do this to make it go back
inside yeah i do let's just suck it back
into your eyebrows
this [ __ ] works okay people yeah i know
that works too i remember uh
i went to go see this movie called in
the fault of our stars in the theater
because
my my lady wanted oh i've seen that
thumbnail yeah we
she we went to the theater to go watch
it and it was the worst decision of my
life because i
cried so [ __ ] hard and everybody in
the theater was just sobbing
and i got mad at my girl because i was
like why the [ __ ] did you take me to
this
because i bro i couldn't it was like i
was getting stressed out with how much i
was crying
it was just so sad but it was such a
bummer of a moment really
do you find it right is it hard for you
to come to terms with crying in front of
your girl
no because she knows that i'm like a
little wuss anyway
but crying is not equated to being a
wuss i'm just as a yes it is you look
worse
the fact that you said worse makes you a
woman oh yeah yeah um
for uh uh for me that's when i feel like
it's actually appropriate to cry
when you're a little wuss no no no no
when you're weakness
when you're when you're with someone
that you love oh so when you cry by
yourself it's way worse because it's
unconditional right like
you know what the acceptance of who you
are i still feel shame like like it's
dumb shame but it's just like like you
that feeling where you know you're
about to cry and you're still trying to
like just fight it like come on just
don't [ __ ] cry right now like
i do that in my head but eventually yeah
but it's
it's not because i feel uncomfortable or
i think she's going to judge me it's
just like this
thing of like don't worry yeah yeah yeah
it's like that you know what unleashes
the water works for me is like when i
already get teary-eyed
and then someone notices it and then
they go like what's wrong
yeah i was crying
they give me a look that they know that
my eyes are too like
look at my lips they're just like this
you know my favorite things about crying
is uh if you're with a girl and you
start crying
that's the best time to ask for favors
i ever had a [ __ ] in two weeks that's
a that's an appropriate time
they all drop babies they're like i'll
give you one yeah i'm gonna try this i'm
gonna try i'm gonna test this out today
and i'll send you guys a result
[Laughter]
so if you want sex in the morning have a
dope conversation
cry your eyes out my eyes out and you're
gonna get it easiest way to cry to
pluck a nose here oh yeah i like that no
there's a clear distinction
there's a clear distinction you got to
be a real cry yeah it has to be
from the soul because people pick up on
energies like you can literally feel the
energy casey's a good actor though
casey could be a he could he could pull
it off i think you could pull it off
yeah thank you all right we'll see he's
behind the camera so he knows
yeah so uh so back to this teacher in
japan
teacher teacher yes you must speak
something very sad in your childhood
yeah this is like peter pan flying it's
like think of a very terrible thought
think of happy games some [ __ ] dust
this is japanese cry dust there's dust
in your eyes japanese
rosa from brooklyn night nine
and then one tear comes out yeah so he
actually brings up the fact that movies
uh
tv shows and literature um are his go-to
uh tools to help people cry and release
and stuff like that dog videos get me
you know which ones get me the most
which ones the ones where they find the
dog like
messed up yes dude it's all shy and [ __ ]
and then they [ __ ] rescue you and
they love that that's exactly what makes
and how beautiful the dog looks after
the colors because like i feel like
geocoin right now dude i feel like we're
connecting
beyond this you know can you help do my
laundry wash the dishes
he's about to ask you for a blow job
watch out like bart asked me to wash
your dishes
[Laughter]
i was crying earlier and uh
i kind of promise that we'll do the
dishes and it was just so sad
so in japan uh there's a stigma in japan
that uh
that people just don't wanna cry there's
a huge and i feel like this extends past
japan i think the whole world is kind of
on the same program we're all wired to
think
that crying is not a it's a weakness or
whatever
and so this man just he's just like well
you know what i we we should
uh embrace the crying thing because he
was saying a lot of japanese literature
has a lot of characters crying and
mourning and all that
on this kind of stuff and he says well
the literature and like our folklore and
folk tales are like that
how come the culture doesn't uh reflect
that and what happened along the way and
then
so a lot of it just happens to be like
just kind of public embarrassment
through a line between like that's
fantasy world this is real world well
there's something that's lost in
translation and i think a lot of people
don't
understand because it's so opposite
right so for
american or western culture it's all
about
expression it's all about individual
like this is who i really am get to know
the real me
versus japan it's actually i respect you
more
when i give you a more professionalism i
respect you i care about you more
because i don't want to infect
you with my bad vibes so even within
family members right
they don't want to inconvenience each
other and they're like yo mom's having a
tough time
let's do our part by being selfless and
even though i'm having a tough time
i'm going to cater to her so the society
makes it where you're constantly
thinking about someone else's needs to
the point where
your needs don't matter anymore yeah
that's sad it is sad but it sounds
like a dope community too though it's
it's culture meaning like there is no
right or wrong
this is how the society evolved right
right and then so
uh there's got to be a balance but
here's the thing right like it's gotten
to the point where
virtuous values is self-sacrifice
and what that means is you want to cry
you want to do your stuff right but if
you start seeing that those needs are
now
burdened to other people then you see it
as a bad trait
which evolves like this where people no
longer understand how to
uh cry or self-suit yeah yeah and that's
the part that he's trying to bring back
is that it is
self-soothing and then like he's even
stating that he's never been sick the
moment he's
actually gone on a regimen of like
crying at least at least once a week
once a week
and uh and it's and for him for him
crying doesn't count when it's like
teary-eyed or whatever like
full song you do need to you hit it out
right now like you need to kind of like
let it all out
to fully get that your spirits back up
or whatever
but the question is how much is too much
crying
like imagine if you were hanging out
yeah like and he was crying like at
least once a day would you feel like a
little
seem like that would even happen in this
case because he's already he has like a
scheduled time of like
release so that wouldn't bleed into the
rest of the days or the rest of the week
so it's like a world
of control yeah yeah yeah it's like
practicing crying
in a controlled environment because you
don't want it to be uncontrollable what
if it wasn't controlled
it's like it's like a werewolf thing
though right like you know it's a full
moon so you're like
sorry guys i gotta go somewhere real
quick but this is this is a service
that's like
extreme though like for people that are
extreme
individuals this is not normal japan you
know that's like my mom like my mom if
you
if i bring up grandma she's already like
or if i go hey mom remember when he used
to beat me
those two topics immediately well that
just means like she has a lot that she
hasn't released about it she needs to
eat some katsu and [ __ ] get that [ __ ]
or she needs to do cry meditation or
she's crying reminiscing
like oh yeah i remember those times
where i beat you up those are good times
man
if grandma was here she beat your ass
too
she'd be so proud
bye